Agora eu me baixei aqui, né?
Tá, tá.
Tu vai se olhar por lá?
Vou.
Cadê o...
Cabo?
É...
60 watts.
Pô, não tem mais...
Salve-noite.
Boa noite.
...
Então, vamos lá, vamos lá.
O que é isso?
Não é um final de 20.
Ela chega na prisão da família.
Mas a gente vai ter que fazer em revisão, tá ligado?
Pra tirar a sua mente.
Pra tirar as fotos que a gente tá no fim da noite.
Ok.
O que é isso?
Assim, então, a gente vai te contar essa conta aí não é?
Mas aí por aí, ele não vem, tá no fim da residência.
Ele vai dar um...
É só assim.
Vou chamar do banderão.
É.
O banderão, mas...
Estou esquecendo, né?
Foi isso.
Estou esquecendo agora.
Estou esquecendo das ligadas.
Sim, é...
A gente vai falar do formato.
Ah, deve ter uma marchada.
Você vai ouvir pra outra coisa.
Na verdade, é um negócio da...
...não é um chave.
É, só uma chave.
Eu pensei, ó.
Você vai achar que tem que falar...
Ela é mossa.
É, mas eu vou...
Eu vou botar...
...como aqui mesmo.
Eu vou botar uma missa.
3,ages.
1,2,1,2,1,1.
Vamos ver.
Tem muita coisa para jogar, mas tem uma coisa para jogar.
Oh, Grindr.
E você está bem?
Está triste.
Você vai se molhar?
Bom.